Speaker 1: kend in the United States. So,
of course, we had another one of these
unspeakable tragedies involving guns. And this one
is particularly bad. We always have mass shootings
in the U.S. It's hard to find a weekend without at
least one mass shooting, but we had a particularly
bad one in this one because of the rhetoric
involved, because of the alleged manifesto left
behind by the alleged killer. We actually have
insight into the stochastic terrorism element
of this situation. So I'm going to explain it to
you. As a reminder, tragically, I've been talking
about stochastic terrorism on this program for
at least 11 years. Back in 2011, I did a segment
called Stochastic Terrorism and Violent Rhetoric,
Unpredictability of Shooters. And the fundamental
idea is that given a large enough audience,
if you pump out a particular message time and
time and time again focusing anger and focusing
resentment and antipathy towards a particular
group of individuals, you will at a certain point
influence someone enough who says, I'm going to go
and shoot a bomb, whatever the case may be.
We've had instances of this in the past,
and here we have one related to so-called gwreat
replacement theory or white replacement theory
and critical race theory and all of
it. So let's take it step by step.
Mass shooting took place over the weekend at Top's
Friendly Market supermarket in Buffalo, New York.
Ten people were killed. Three were injured. Of the
13 victims, 11 were black and two were white. And
this was not a coincidence. This was not by mere
chance. This is being considered a hate crime.
The shooter live streamed part of the attack
on Twitch. Twitch says they caught it within 2
minutes and cut the stream. The shooter is white,
18 year old and deliberately traveled to an area
with a higher population of black people because
he wanted to kill black people. The shooter was
wearing body armor and a military grade helmet and
armed with three firearms, a semi-automatic rifle,
allegedly, allegedly a Bushmaster XM 15, a
hunting rifle and a shotgun. That's what we
know right now. And had a head mounted camera.
That's the camera from which the event was
streamed. The suspect was captured alive and was
arraigned in the Buffalo City Court on the day of
the shooting represented by a public defender.
Felony hearings scheduled to begin later this
week in front of a grand jury. He's being held
without bail. Now, this is where it starts to get,
you know, oh, don't make it political. Well, right
wing political media literally wrote the script
for this guy's manifesto. He reportedly wrote The
Shooter and a 180 page manifesto that was released
prior to the shooting. I'm not going to publish
the manifesto, but you can find it. I'll give you
some of the highlights. And there's actually
a good Twitter thread by JJ McNabb, a fellow
at George Washington University's Program on
Extremism. Some of the things from the manifesto
The shooter self-identifies as a white supremacist
fascist with neo-Nazi beliefs who is anti high
fertility immigrants. Under the white replacement
theory. This is the idea that immigrants who
aren't white come to the U.S. to have a lot of
kids to demographically take over the country.
He states he was radicalized online on four
channel and was inspired by Brenton Tarrant
Manifesto and livestreamed mass shooting in
New Zealand. You might remember that one.
The shooter chose this target because it has a
higher percentage of black Americans than other
nearby areas. The manifesto is 180 pages long.
Dozens of pages are nothing more than anti-black
and anti-Semitic memes and statistics, and almost
100 pages contained mind numbingly boring info
about every piece of equipment he considered
taking on the shooting spree. Now, there is so
much to talk about here. There's the mentally
ill thing right there. This way. Oftentimes,
you know, we've seen this before and and I
don't do this, but you often see the trend of
if the shooter is Muslim, then it's radical
beliefs that are responsible and the community
of the individual. If it's a young white dude,
then it's a lone mentally ill guy who's mental
illness alone and not the fact that the
manifesto reads like a Fox News script
are responsible. It's important to remember a
couple of things. One, in some sense you can
argue any of these people are not mentally right.
Anybody willing to do this is not mentally right.
But when you look at the manifesto, it's perfectly
cogent and coherent. And it's not someone who
doesn't understand the consequences of their
actions. And most importantly, most mentally ill
people are not violent. Most mentally
ill people. Never commit a violent act.
Look at the list of so-called mental illnesses.
Now, I know that not all of these are exactly
the same category, but think about, you
know, anxiety, bipolar disorder, depression,
OCD, paranoia, paranoid schizophrenia, delusional
disorder, borderline personality disorder,
mania, panic disorder, PTSD, Depersonalization D
Realization disorder. Anorexia, bulimia, parasite.
Manias, kleptomania. This is a broad range of
stuff, but the point is, almost none of the folks
with those conditions ever become violent. Now I
get that something is wrong with the people who
are violent. But to say, Oh, well, this is just
a mental just a therapist solves this problem,
ignoring the political motivations, ignoring
the access to firearms, ignoring all of it.
When you look at the manifesto, it's articulate.
Fastest. Fascist. Racist. Hate linked to ideas
that we see in corporate media. The talk
about white birthrates. The document talks
about critical race theory. That's something
I mean, listen, that it's like a Republican
talking point at this point in time. It says that
it's all part of a Jewish plot. And oftentimes
there's anti-Semitism in this stuff. It's the
full complement of the things they've been
pushing openly since Trump became president, even
since right before when his campaign started. Now,
let's just look at some examples. Here's Ben
SHAPIRO. Democrats want open borders. They want
to bring in tens of millions of illegals to vote.
Speaker 2: The Biden administration has done less
than nothing. They're not talking about ending
Title 42, which would basically allow the borders
to be swamped. Their own DHS decimating up
to 18,000 people a day, maybe descending
on the border, which of course, completely
destroys whatever semblance of order there is
on the border. There isn't much there right now.
So what do you make of the border situation?
Speaker 3: It's I think it's literally criminal.
What Biden and the administration has done,
you know, they swore to faithfully defend
and uphold the laws of the United States.
Speaker 1: And and remember,
almost nothing different is
being done by Biden versus Trump at the border.
Speaker 3: It's not even like they're trying.
It's not like they're trying and failing. Right.
That would be bad enough. Mere incompetence be
costly enough. But they just want this open
border. This is their policy program. From the
Democrats perspective, they like it. It's good.
It's 225,000 people coming across every month,
not every year. Every month. The amount of
fentanyl that comes over every month is enough
to kill every American twice over. Of course,
most of the people brought over are trafficked by
cartels. So there's a human slavery component. You
know, the women and children are horribly abused.
Bona fide humanitarian crisis. And it's just bad.
It's bad for everybody in Arizona. It's bad for
the whole country. But this is the way Democrats
like it. And again, I'm bold enough to admit the
obvious. Right, which is that they're doing this
so that someday they can amnesty these people
and make them voters who they expect to vote
Democrat. This is an electoral strategy for
the Democrats. Their policies are so bad.
Speaker 1: And so so we've already debunked
this extensively, even if it was what
Democrats wanted to do. It's a terrible,
terrible strategy. Strategy. And I've explained
many times why the math of it doesn't make any
sense. But the point is here is that anger at
Democrats deliberately dumping in tens of millions
of illegals into the country, that's not what
Democrats want to do. Tucker Carlson. Remember,
immigrants make our country poorer and dirtier.
Speaker 2: Good evening and welcome to Tucker
Carlson tonight. Here's a funny thing we
noticed the other day. People debate all
the time about mass immigration. What you
never hear anybody do is make the economic
case for mass immigration. But as an economic
matter, this is insane. It's indefensible. So
nobody even tries to defend it. Instead, our
leaders demand that you shut up and accept
this. We have a moral obligation to admit the
world's poor. They tell us, even if it makes our
own country poorer and dirtier and more divided.
Speaker 1: I mean, it's hard to get more
specific rhetoric than that. That
is straight out of the manifesto.
Here is another Tucker Carlson clip where he is
doing the replacement theory talking points that
were echoed in the shooter's manifesto.
Speaker 2: I'm laughing because this is
one of about ten stories that I know you've
covered where the government shows preference
to people who have shown absolutely
contempt for our customs, our laws,
our system itself, and they're being treated
better than American citizens. Now, I know
that the left and all the little gatekeepers
on Twitter become literally hysterical if you
use the term replacement, if you suggest that the
Democratic Party is trying to replace the current
electorate, the voters now casting ballots with
new people, more obedient voters from the Third
World. But they become hysterical because that's
that's what's happening, actually. Let's just say
it. That's true. If if look, if this was happening
in your house, if you were in sixth grade,
for example, and without telling.
Speaker 1: I remember covering
this at the time. Listen to this.
Speaker 2: Your kit, your parents
adopted a bunch of new siblings and gave them
brand new bikes and let them stay up later
and help them with their homework and gave
them twice the allowance that they gave you.
You. You would say to your siblings, you know,
I think we're being replaced by by kids that
our parents love more. And it becomes.
Speaker 1: This is the great replacement
theory stuff that was in the manifesto.
Charlie Kirk has been pushing this stuff.
Speaker 2: President Joe Biden's Department of
Defense will accept 30,000 Afghan refugees in the
military installations following the collapse of
Kabul. But. Political transformation. There it is.
Let the country crumble. Do you know there's 5
million displaced people in Afghanistan now? This
was all intentional. Joe Biden let it fall apart
to now say, oh, I'm so sorry. I guarantee you,
Joe Biden's speech was afternoon. We'll talk about
refugee assistance and relocation support. Yep.
Speaker 1: The entire point of getting out
of Afghanistan was so it would go poorly
so that then they can bring in people to
replace white people from Afghanistan.
Lauren Boebert has done this stuff.
Speaker 4: Yes, there is definitely a
replacement theory that's going on right now.
We are killing American jobs and bringing in
illegal aliens from all over the world to replace
them. If Americans will not comply, replace them.
Speaker 1: Replace them. So there is serious
responsibility here. I'm not saying there's going
to be accountability. I'm not saying what they're
doing is criminal. The term stochastic terrorism
is not a criminal term. It's a term that
we as reasonable people can say, wow,
they repeat this rhetoric, and then the rhetoric
is used in a manifesto and it's what made this guy
go and seek out black people. I'm not saying you
can charge any of them. I'm just saying we have
to speak honestly and acknowledge that these ideas
didn't come out of thin air. Now, one other note
before we move on. This was not the only mass
shooting this weekend. So, yes, there was the
mass shooting in Buffalo, but we also had a mass
shooting in Milwaukee with 17 injuries on Friday.
And we also had mass shootings in Houston, Texas,
Laguna Woods, California, Amarillo, Texas, as well
as Winston-Salem, North Carolina this weekend. So
always remember, in the United States of America,
there is never just one mass shooting. And we do
ultimately get to the question of what do we do?
Because there's this fallacy of tolerance. If
we tolerate the intolerant, then they go out
and kill people. And they those people that die no
longer can practice that tolerance. There is this
fallacy there and this problem that needs
to be dealt with. And we're going to keep
covering all of this. But we of course, we have
to talk about what Fox News is blaming as well